-Guys, today is Friday,
and that's usually
when I catch up
on some personal stuff.
I check my inbox
and return some emails
and, of course,
I send out thank you notes.
I was running behind --
[ Cheering and applause ]
Can I write out some thank you
notes right now? Is that okay?
[ Cheering and applause ]
Thank you.
James, can I get some thank you
note-writing music, please?
[ Playing tender tune ]
Ooh.
[ Laughter ]
-It's George Santos.
-Oh, my gosh.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know how he does it.
-Yeah.
Every week.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you,
Instagram quiet mode,
for letting me focus
on the things
that really matter in life --
TikToks.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-[ Clucking ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, Canada,
for changing
your recommendations
on alcohol consumption
from two drinks a day
to two drinks a week.
[ Laughter ]
And, for Canadians
who can't handle that,
maybe it's time to look into AA,
eh eh?
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheering ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, news of a "Megan"
sequel in 2025.
Of course, Meghan will be
a teenager by then,
so, instead of murdering people,
she'll just make cruel remarks
that destroy
their self-esteem.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
-Wow.
"You smell."
[ Laughter ]
"You're going
to wear that shirt?"
[ Laughter ]
-"Again?"
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you,
news that men who use Viagra
are likely to live longer.
Or, as guys put it,
[ Haltingly ]
"Finally, a reason for me
to begin taking Viagra."
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
How do you do it?
-Yeah. Oh.
It's blue!
[ Laughter ]
-That's what he says
after he takes it?
-Yeah.
-[ As Jerry Lewis ] Whoa!
-[ As Lewis ] Whoa!
-Whoa, boy!
-Hello! [ Pops cheek ]
[ Laughter ]
Ring the bell.
-Hoo, boy.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, dry January,
for being followed up
with Forget It February
and Marchgarita.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Marchgarita.
Boing!
Oh, boy!
-Hoh-hoy, it's blue!
-Egg smuggler.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, January,
for being God's chance
to put the weather on shuffle.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheering ]
-Aww.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you, Tom Brady,
for making me feel better
about not having
any plans this weekend.
[ Cheering and applause ]
There you have it.
Those are my Thank You Notes.
We'll be right back
with Colin Jost! Come on.